hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
i've got the most incredible ridiculous
gift for you on this video i'm going to
share with you right now
i want to spend two days with you guess
what the property investors crash course
is back
it's back did you hear that did you hear
that amanda the crash course is back
it's like no work listen two full days
right now
right now i'm in durham this is gonna be
in london wherever you are in the world
right now
find a way to get to london because i'm
gonna be there
i've booked a venue i booked the ibis
hotel
it's like the biggest hotel room we
could find in london
and uh there's gonna be hundreds and
hundreds of people there i promise you
this
this will sell out this is going to sell
out
i'll tell you what it's going to sell
out because the oil sells out
every time we run a crash course this is
the first crash course
since the pandemic right now with the
pandemic
with everything that's going on over a
million pounds sorry over a million
people
have lost their jobs people are losing
their jobs so what i'm going to be
teaching
for literally two days the cost
for you right now is one pound one pound
today's black friday one pound i'm gonna
be there for two full straight days
this guy's gonna be there he's gonna be
there you're gonna see him there
amanda's gonna be there and i'm gonna
have a lot of people there that are
financially free
that are gonna be working with you
they're gonna be journeying with you
it costs one pound hmos lease option
agreements
rent to rent deal packaging everything
that i've learned
over the last 12 years in property doing
over 300 deals
i'm going to condense and i'm going to
share with you over the two days
for one pound so get yourself booked on
real quick
because i'll tell you something amanda
is this going to sell out
yes but it always sells out it's going
to sell out how fast if you were there
how fast would you book
uh now i would vote right now it's one
pound
it's crazy like honestly i'm you know
what let me tell you why i'm doing this
i'm doing this
from a position of mission you know i
mean listen i've made millions
and millions of pounds in property i've
made millions of pounds
and hundreds and hundreds of people have
become financially free
as a direct result of the teaching and
you're gonna receive
the exact same training it all starts at
the crash course
for one pound two days with me so
that's what's happening that's why i'm
so stoked and you know what i'll tell
you something
property is the most lucrative
profession on the planet
and right now there's ridiculous
opportunities in the market this is the
opportunity of a decade
so that's why i say wherever you are get
booked on
i want to meet you you know i want to
get to know you i want to meet you
i want to do a selfie with you i want to
give you all the foundations
foundations and grounding of property to
get you started so you don't need to
rely on someone you don't need to
work 40 hours a week for 40 years to
retire and 40 of what you couldn't
afford to live on in the first place you
don't have to worry about
whether your boss is going to like you
in case he makes you redundant because
they let a lot of people go
you're gonna stand on your own two feet
as a result of the training
that you're gonna receive for one pound
so book right now
click the link i'm stoked it's black
friday it's one pound there is a no show
fee
uh so if you book on and then you just
don't turn up that's an issue um but
you're not gonna do that you're gonna be
there you're gonna be on time
and you know what i really believe that
there's gonna be a lot
of people that become financially free
over the next three
to six months as a direct result of the
two days that i'm going to be running
at the crash course in the coming i
think it's like when is it what's the
day
i don't know click the link and see the
day okay but it's coming
it's in london travel wherever you are
don't be like oh but i live in
manchester great
you're in the same country then get down
let's spend two days together
don't make excuses make it happen click
the link i'll see you there i can't wait
[Applause]
you're only going to be mind blown
that's how i'm going to put it
samuel's just an amazing ball of energy
samuel is great
he's very very passionate he's got a
massive heart he loves teaching and
seeing successful people
and he's very sort of in there getting
it done and let's just get this done no
matter what
no barriers let's get it done just spend
two days of your life and you know
and just come and do it and then see
different options and probably change
your
thinking and just go for it the time
invested here
is going to pay you back in the future
if you listen to what you have heard
if you put your tools into use and what
you've heard into action
then it will pay you back in time and in
money if you never try coming to the
crash course you'll never know what will
change your life
you could be thinking what would have
happened if i didn't go
you know 10 years down the line
someone's life could have changed but
your life would still remain the same
samuel does a pretty outstanding job and
i think the selflessness
of him doing the course for people like
myself
for free and it is for free there's no
catches or anything that behind it
it is genuinely two days of his time
giving back to everybody which is pretty
phenomenal
there's zero to lose but there's such an
empowerment discourse let alone
a set of new knowledge it genuinely is
empowering you meet some great people
i can't say enough the value of what
you're going to get from here
it has the potential to change your life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
experience
so right now i urge you to take this
opportunity
click the link in the description and it
will take you straight through to the
website
and you can book within literally a
minute or two
claim your free tickets now it's back
it's december
um if you just click here you can see
there's 18 people just on the website
right now
18 people just on the website right now
booking on this is going to sell out
it's going to sell out really quick
um you're gonna fill this this little
format right here and you can see it's a
pound
there's no catch it's a pound um crash
course
crash course dates are 11th and 12th of
december 19th and 20th of december
and it is a pound so i think this is
your red diamond moment
you're watching this for a reason get
booked on before it sells out
and i can't wait to see you at the
property investors crash course
thanks
[Music]
below